SPEAKER 1: Today, we're talking
about so serverless exports,
Windows Server VMs, and
regular expressions.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia, and
welcome to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you
the lowest latency
news from the safety of home.
Whether you're maintaining
backups or feeding
downstream analytics, exporting
data out of your databases
can put a strain on
your production systems.
In order to make it easier
to schedule and maintain
these data exports, we've
launched a new feature
for Cloud SQL,
serverless exports.
Severless exports enables you
to export data from your MySQL
and PostgreSQL
database instances
without any impact, or
performance, or risk
to your production workloads.
Google Cloud is
dedicated to providing
a first-class experience for
migrating and modernizing
Windows workloads.
That's why we have just
announced several new features,
all designed to make it easier
to manage your Windows Server
workloads.
There are three new
features in beta--
boot screen diagnostics, auto
upgrades for Windows 2008,
and diagnostic
information collection.
In addition, we've released a
tool designed around improved
licensing reporting.
The most daunting part
of cloud computing
is often the idea of
migrating to the cloud.
That's why these solution
architects collected
their advice and best practices
into a comprehensive set
of documents for the teams
who are planning, designing,
and implementing a
migration to Google Cloud.
This blog post provides
a high-level outline
of their guidance with links
to the relevant documentation.
Finally, Cloud Logging
just got an upgrade
to support regular expressions
in our query language.
To celebrate this moment,
the software engineering
lead for this project sat
down to share his best
tips for getting the
most from your logs.
Check out the interview
in the blog post.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
to see a full list, check
out the links below.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.